peter schiff is a perma-bear people love
to dunk on him on the internet but he
recently was on fox business and he got
a couple of things right that i think
are worth calling out here is peter's
appearance on the show i want to start
with you peter
what does this mean for the fed what's
the fed's next move next week as it
begins its two-day meeting on september
20th well the fed is going to hike rates
i doubt they'll go 100 basis points but
even if they did it would not matter you
know i don't understand why markets are
still surprised when you get higher than
expected inflation numbers inflation is
going to continue to get stronger even
as the economy gets weaker and in fact
the fed actually falls further behind
the inflation curve every time it hikes
rates because these rate hikes are too
little too late the fed needs to make
interest rates positive to do anything
to bend the curve they have to get rates
above the rate of inflation and until
they do that they're spitting in the
wind and meanwhile what really has to
happen is we need massive cuts in
government spending and the government
is doing the opposite we have the the
inflation reduction act we have the the
chips act we have forgiving student
loans all of this is additional spending
which is the worst thing you want to do
when you have an inflation problem the
first thing that peter said is that the
fed is going to have to bring interest
rates up above the rate of inflation if
they want to actually get inflation down
the problem though is that the fed
continues to be behind the curve they're
acting too little too late and because
inflation continues to get stronger
while the economy continues to get
weaker it means that the fed has no
control they cannot get inflation down
in the manner that they're saying but
the even bigger thing that peter called
out which i totally agree with is that
the fed is in a gun battle with the
politicians the fed are creating tighter
financial conditions they're trying to
bring inflation down but at the exact
same time politicians are drunk they
continue to spend like there's no
tomorrow every single bill that they put
forward that spends money makes
inflation worse you have the fed trying
to create tighter financial conditions
while the politicians are working
against them that is a recipe for
disaster now peter of course couldn't
leave the show without also issuing a
stark warning about a dire financial
situation that is upon us here's what
peter had to say about where we're
headed peter speak to our investor
audience before we go here what is your
best piece of advice at the moment
yeah well first of all you know you
mentioned that gold is down and the
reason that it's down is because
investors still don't understand that
the fed is going to lose this fight with
inflation that the economy is not only
already in a recession but headed
towards another financial crisis and so
the fed despite rising inflation is
ultimately going to try to stimulate the
economy and so we're going to have the
combination of a massive recession or
depression with a financial crisis and
rising inflation so all of this is
bullish for gold it's bearish for the
dollar so my advice is to your viewers
is to tune out all the noise about how
how the fed is going to succeed and how
it's going to bring inflation back down
to two percent and you better invest as
if the fed is going to fail not succeed
this is not 1980. uh powell is not paul
volcker you've got to do the opposite of
what worked during the 1980s you got to
do it worked in the 70s and that is
getting out of u.s stocks getting out of
u.s bonds and getting into commodities
foreign assets and gold now the big
question here is peter wright about what
he sees in the future i don't know and i
don't think anyone else in the market
knows either but if peter schiff was
right about his analysis of where we are
currently that means that you should at
least think about what he's saying of
where we're going it would be a sad sad
situation if many of the market
intervention tactics both in the federal
reserve and from politicians ended up
creating some sort of financial crisis
or even worse a financial depression now
my base case isn't that that is what is
going to happen but peter schiff seems
to think that's where we're going let me
know in the comments how do you evaluate
where we are now and where do you think
that we're headed is it a rosy picture
or should we be bunkering down for some
sort of chaos hey you did you like this
video great make sure you subscribe like
the video and see you next time